من التفاصيل من الجانب الاسرائيلي ربما
ماذا تقول اسرائيل نجوان سمري من تل ابيب
تنضم الينا تفضلي
نجوان يعني دعيني اشير ليلى الى اننا من
هذا الموقع رصدنا عدد من الاعتراضات
الجويه لمنظومه القبه الحديديه لهذه
الصواريخ التي اطلقت ووصلت الى مناطق
واسعه في مدينه تل ابيب ولكن ايضا في تل
ابيب ال الكبرى من ينظر ال الى خارطه
الانذارات التي دوت فيها صافرات الانذارات
قبل قليل في منطقه تل ابيب يرى بانها قد
صبغت على نطاق واسع في اللون الاحمر عده
مدن وبلدات تقع الى الجنوب من مدينه تل
ابيب ايضا دوت فيها هذه الصافرات دفعه
واحده وهناك عمليات تمشيط وبحث واسعه بدات
تجريها الشرطه الاسرائيليه لتحديد مواقع
قد تكون سقطت فيها شذا القذائف او بعض
القذائف في بحسب المعلومات الاوليه كانت
بالفعل قد سقطت شضايا و قضائ صاروخيه في
منطقه اللد مدينه اللد الواقعه الى الجنوب
من مدينه تل ابيب ولكن ايضا في بيت دجان
وبحسب ايضا المعلومات فانه على الاقل هذه
الدفعه الصاروخيه اشتملت على
15 صاروخا اطلقت من جنوب خان يونس وهذا
هذه النقطه في غايه الاهميه ان عمليه
الاطلاق الى هذه المناطق بحسب وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه اطلقت من جنوب مدينه خان يونس
بمعنى ان المدى للاطلاق يفوق المدى عندما
يتم اطلاق وتوجيه هذه الصواريخ من المنطقه
الشماليه في قطاع غزه اي اننا نتحدث عن
اكثر ربما من 80 وحتى 90
م مدى هذا هذه الدفعه الصاروخيه الاسعاف
الاسرائيلي يقول بانه يقوم ايضا بتمشيط
المناطق التي قد تكون سقطت فيها شضايا حتى
الان لم يتم التبليغ عن وقوع اصابات لكن
من الواضح انه في اليومم عشر بعد المئه ان
يتم اطلاق صواريخ الى منطقه تل ابيب وتل
ابيب الكبرى هذا يربك الى حد كبير الاجهزه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه الجيش الاسرائيلي
وايضا القياده السياسيه في اسرائيل التي
لا تتوقف عن الحديث
والتذكير بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي حقق انجازات كبيره عسكريه في
هذه الحرب ومنها بطبيعه الحال تقليص
القضائ الصاروخيه التي تطلق من قطاع غزه
لكن في الايام الاخيره الماضيه راينا انه
يعني ان كان هناك تراجع في اطلاق الصواريخ
الا ان هناك طيله الوقت صافرات تدو في
مناطق الغلاف والان للمره الثانيه في هذا
الشهر او الثالثه على ما اذكر تدوي صافرات
الانذار في مدينه تل ابيب نحن نذكر ان هذا
العام الجديد عند الساعه الثان ع عند
منتصف الليل كانت قد اطلقت دفعه الى مدينه
تل ابيب لتذكر ربما بان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ما زالت قادره على توجيه مثل
هذه الضربات الى قلب اسرائيل وليس فقط الى
بلدات الغلاف نحن نتحدث عن هذه المناطق
التي يعني من جهه هي ابعد بكثير من منطقه
الغلاف عن مدينه غزه وعن قطاع غزه لكن
ايضا لها رمزيتها تل ابيب هي المدينه
الاقتصاديه والتجاريه والعاصمه الاقتصاديه
والتجاريه بالنسبه لاسرائيل كذلك فيما
يتعلق بالقطاع السياحي لكن من جهه اخرى
تتعامل اسرائيل مع هذه المدينه بحساسيه
اكبر عندما يتم توجيه الصواريخ الى الى
قلب ووسط مدينه اسرائيل وتحديدا عندما
نتحدث الى هذه المده التي لم يتوقف فيها
الجيش الاسرائيلي عن قصف المقاومه وضرب
البنى التحتيه ومثل هذه المنصات لاطلاق
الصواريخ تحتاج الى اماكن واسعه من اجل
توجيه هذه الصواريخ فهذا يعني امر يمكن
وصفه بالمعجزه ليلى في هذا التوقيت بالذات
بعد 115 يوما من هذهب
نحلل ونحاول ان نفهم ما الذي يجري الان في
تل ابيب مع